good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today is scp
4290
containment class ketter
disruption class amita
and risk class critical
special containment procedures
all available military assets are at the
site of
scp-4290 ceiling and are prepared to use
any means necessary to neutralize the
anomaly mobile task force alpha 1 red
right hand mobile task force tau 5
samsara and mobile task force new 7
hammered down have been outfitted with
experimental paratech weaponry and are
situated within
scp-4290's containment perimeter grids
of nuclear mines have been planted in
the vicinity of the ceiling site
prepared to detonate if foundation
assets are destroyed the de gauze break
orbital strike system has been enabled
in the event of a breach past the
containment perimeter
emergency shelters for civilians and
selected foundation personnel are being
prepared in the event that containment
measures fail the probability of failure
is undetermined
description
scp-4290 is a class 1 eschatological
entity that was thaumaturgically sealed
approximately 10 000 years in the past
its seal is expected to break in the
next seven days
the site of ceiling
scp-4290 lockk is in qinghai lake at a
depth of 32.8 meters from the surface
and is constructed from eight beryllium
bronze totems the totems resemble
armored humans engraved with networks of
banishing runes and arranged onto the
points of an eight-fold fractal pattern
carved into the lake bed 20 meters wide
bursts of red light are periodically
released from its center these have
intensified in brightness over the past
month
information on
scp-4290 has been recovered from
scp-1726 and other such anomalous record
sources a translated excerpt on the
entity from an unknown writer follows
the child rose its ten mouths to the
heaven stretched wide twenty arms and
ripped the umbilical cord from the sack
on its head
the warriors surged to its legs hoping
to tear those newly born limbs before
they could move but from the mouths
spilled torrents of darkness
and dead geometries
none could flee reality rippled with the
warriors stretching along its folds and
the darkness crunched into their skulls
with flares of scarlet the child wheezed
dragging skeletal fingers through the
dead and the land around
the fingers retracted flames burst then
subsided wax rained then dissolved then
the island its warriors and every soul
still left melted into the darkness for
ten days the child drank it
all the world trembled
addendum 4290 1 repair attempts
on o 208 2022 televisions in jinghai
province and outlying areas abruptly
displayed images of an entity matching
scp-4290
rising over a melting cityscape with an
androgynous voice telling viewers to
repair the child's locks this has
repeated in frequency with the voice
shifting to say there is little time
left repair
investigation led to the discovery of
scp-4290
l-o-c-k
efforts into finding means by which
scp-4290-l-o-c-k
could be reinforced or launched searches
of scp-1726
undercover excursions into the wanderers
library and the ruins of specific far
past civilizations found that this is
not the first time the seal has needed
repairs civilizations including the eric
keshens the jia dynasty and ancient
artothens have strengthened the seal
with sacrificial rituals and the
engraving of new runes onto the totems
the last group to have performed this
were the davites shortly before their
culture was destroyed c270
the foundation department of occult
containment arranged for the rights and
engravings to be performed a submersible
containing the ritual setup and remotely
operated underwater vehicles with
carving equipment descended to the
center of
scp-4290 loc on 0908 2022 however
halfway through the performance of the
ritual a red light burst accompanied
with the release of high levels of gamma
radiation and heat occurred radiation
damage caused the rovs to accidentally
damage existing runes and the
interruption of the ritual lead to only
two cadavers and half the heart to
vanish as planned
television broadcasts repeated later
that day its voice now stating
the sacrifice did not reach the 10 maws
race
addendum 4290 to 1508 2022 defection
incident
at 1 am several personnel stationed at
qinghai lake acted against foundation
orders and fled the area one of the
involved agents agent zenovia mourinho's
left the following message on a piece of
paper in their quarters before leaving
do we think we can actually stop this
no civilization before us wanted to
fight the child
none of them
algia had tech better than anything
we've got and even they were afraid the
sacrifices don't work anymore it refuses
to consume them they aren't enough to
satiate it once that seal breaks we'll
have a world of molten darkness and the
child will be all that's left
eating
drinking
you're fools for staying
the activation of ways to
extra-dimensional spaces was detected
nearby tracking is not considered a
priority
addendum 4293
ceiling updates
1608 2022
seismometers have detected a series of
high-energy seismic pulses radiating
directly under
scp-4290 loc consistent with models on
the effects of dimensional distortion on
terrain red light now encompasses the
entire ceiling site and the totems are
observed to be crumbling
personnel are advised to wait and
prepare
this file has been revised displaying
new additions
addendum 4290 for
scenario 4290 unlock
on 1708 2022 the totems comprising
scp-4290 lockk disintegrated military
assets assembled at the shore of ching
hai lake and 10 minutes later a 40-meter
long emaciated humanoid organism
matching descriptions of
scp-4290 phased out of the ground and
onto the seabed orders were sent to only
fire once activity was observed
personnel waited two hours
after a further hour of waiting rovs
were sent to scp-4290
followed by an expeditionary crew
equipped with lambda model thamato
hazard suits dozens of human corpses and
hearts used in the sacrificial repair
rituals rested on the entity's mouths
none having been consumed no thank
radiation sine wave emissions or any
signs of activity were registered all
life functions in
scp-4290 had ceased
insight autopsies were performed based
on these the entity is estimated to have
died approximately 9 000 years ago the
cause of death was determined to be
malnutrition
scp-4290 has been reclassified to
neutralize
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to tomothy
anvil
zargaran
professor puffer
nobody
will remember
vino
gavios the hollow
zazzapan
jordan c wilde
lam k
dr briggs
tailored printers
segnar
aletreon
your local foundation agent
derivative
gabriel hawkins
lost boy
a real american hebrew
the morrigan
james sabha
and
nj vojak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos and some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you